Apple's iPhone 15 Pro is now here and
while many people have found it a bit
disappointing compared to previous years
if you look closely there are actually
some really nice new features that might
just get you to upgrade so in this video
I'll go through the top 10 new features
in no particular order except that I'm
Gonna Leave the best three features for
last so make sure you watch through this
entire video so you don't miss them
starting from the top with feature
number 10 we have the brand new action
button which is something very new and
exciting because we've been stuck with
the ringer switch since the very first
iPhone ever the action button basically
gives you a ton of different options to
launch apps and give you instant access
to features like your flashlight Focus
modes or opening your camera app and
taking photos all without having to
Fumble around with your iPhone to wake
the display and try to swipe or long
press the camera button and then making
it even better you will have infinite
customizability since you can launch
shortcuts which can basically do
anything you want from turning on your
smart home accessories at home to
opening basically any app out there now
for feature number nine we have the
thinner display bezels which is
something that you get to experience day
to day because you're always looking at
your phone and the super thin bezels
definitely make everything seem a more
immersive especially watching videos or
movies and on the pro Max model the
bezels seem even thinner thanks to the
larger display area and I think the
actual size of the phone will be
slightly smaller than before so it'll
more easily fit into your hands and your
pocket moving on to feature number eight
we have an upgrade to eight gigs of RAM
which will help make your phone feel a
bit more Snappy in terms of General
performance and especially when
multitasking with multiple apps open at
the same time but that's not even the
main Improvement you get from having
eight gigs of RAM but before I explain
that I want to show you guys the most
Innovative and essential new macsafe
product from our partner moft which is
their new snap invisible phone tripod
stand this thing is incredibly unique
because it's super thin and it just
stays on the back of your iPhone using
Mac safe but in an instant you can
unfold it into an elevated stand like
this seriously look at this I've never
seen this before on any product because
it elevates it higher than any other
stand and it's super nice and thin this
is honestly gonna be perfect for doing
FaceTime or Zoom calls and probably for
Content creators on Tick Tock doing some
videos with how much adjustability that
you also get with this really strong
hinge you can even angle it down like
this and shoot hands-free macro video of
things on your table and you can also
Mount your iPhone sideways for watching
videos or movies very conveniently but I
can totally see myself using this all
the time to take group photos on a timer
with my friends and family on the iPhone
15 Pro since this is so stable and has
so much angle adjustability it's also
got mops super nice new movas vegan
leather finish and you can order it
today using the link in the description
below now getting back to the iPhone 15
Pro's top features the main Improvement
you get from 8 gigs of RAM is that
you'll be able to run and cycle through
more apps without them closing on you
when you come back to them which used to
happen all the time with pause YouTube
videos Twitter and Facebook that would
totally reset which was super annoying
but now it's gotten a lot better and
it'll probably be Flawless with the 8
gigs of RAM on the 15 Pro for feature
number seven we have the new a17 Pro
chip now while the 10 Single core and 20
graphics performance improvements don't
seem that great compared to our
expectations there are definitely some
good improvements with this new chip
Apple mentioned that this new chip is
more efficient so sustained performance
should be getting an improvement
especially while gaming where in the
past the power would kind of Spike all
over the place due to The Thermals so we
should now get more consistent
performance the new a17 Pro also comes
with a redesigned neural engine that is
now twice as fast which is solely
responsible for a bunch of the new
camera related features that I'm going
to talk about later on in this video the
a17 pro also comes with a dedicated av1
decoder which takes care of playback of
YouTube videos and anything else with
that codec to improve efficiency and
there's also a new USB controller which
I'll get into in just a minute and don't
forget the new hardware Ray tracing
which makes it a pro class GPU to
support the AAA games of the future like
the four that Apple just announced
getting into feature number six we have
the brand new 5x telephoto camera for
the iPhone 15 Pro Max the new camera
uses a new Tetra prism lens design which
reflects light four times inside of the
camera which basically creates the
necessary light distance required to
reach 5x Zoom which is actually very
Innovative compared to the rest of the
industry every other phone with a 5x
lens uses a periscope lens design which
is basically a smaller side mounted
sensor which means that the camera bump
and phone itself need to be a bit
thicker to support it and a huge benefit
with the new 5x camera is that the
aperture is the same F 2.8 as the 3x
lens which means that it'll take in the
same amount of light so low light photos
will look just as good and there won't
be any additional noise now moving on to
feature number five we have a silent
upgrade that Apple didn't really mention
which is Wi-Fi 6E support on the 15 Pro
Models this finally enables the new 6
gigahertz Wi-Fi band so you can get even
faster speeds than before and it enables
thread support so you can get a
dedicated Network for connecting and
controlling products in your home
essentially being a low power and low
latency mesh Network for feature number
four we have the fact that Apple finally
redesigned the iPhone 15 pro and pro
Max's chassis so that it's more easily
replaced which is a huge deal for the
repair industry and not only that but it
has a big Advantage for regular users
since it just became much less expensive
to replace the back glass if it gets
cracked or damaged so that's a big bonus
feature for anyone who drops their
iPhone a lot and has cracked the back
glass in the past and now for the actual
top three features of the iPhone 15 Pro
in order let's start with number three
which is the new titanium metal design
this right here is a big deal because
we've been stuck with stainless steel
since the iPhone 10 so it's really nice
to get something unique and fresh again
with the brushed titanium look but there
are actually some real benefits to the
titanium other than Aesthetics and
design first of all it makes the Iphone
15 Pro Models around 10 lighter than the
previous ones which will definitely be
noticeable in the hands and it'll make
it hurt less when you accidentally drop
it on your face while laying down in bed
and dozing off another benefit is that
it won't be as glossy anymore so it's
going to have better fingerprint
resistance and titanium also gives the
iPhone better heat dissipation so games
will run better as well as other apps
that put a consistent load on the chip
overall it just looks and feels more
premium and high-end than before knowing
it's made out of titanium just like how
the Apple watch Ultra really looks
premium while being lightweight now for
top feature number two 2 we have the new
24 megapixel camera output and the new
automatic portrait mode for the first
time in eight years Apple's iPhone 15
and 15 Pro Models now automatically
shoot 24 megapixel photos as the new
standard instead of 12 megapixels like
it's always been now with a 24 megapixel
output by default using the main 1X
camera photos should look noticeably
more sharp compared to previous iPhone
models and Android phones and especially
if you zoom in and do some pixel peeping
now at the same time Apple also
announced automatic portrait mode which
will turn on portrait mode whenever it
detects a face or a person and even
further the regular camera mode will now
capture depth data even when you're not
using portrait mode so that you can go
in later and turn it into a portrait
photo as well as change the focus point
which is an absolute absolutely great
feature which can save portrait shots
that were misfocused and my favorite
part about this feature is that it means
we now finally have 24 megapixel
portrait photos compared to last year on
the 14 pro where every single portrait
was always limited to 12 megapixels with
no option to shoot 48 megapixel Pro raw
portrait photos and now for the number
one new iPhone 15 Pro feature we of
course have the switch to USBC this is
by far the biggest deal because the
lightning Port has been holding the
iPhone back for far too long especially
the 14 Pro Models which could shoot in
high quality prores this will be a huge
deal for allowing you to use just one
cable for your iPad your Mac and your
iPhone you can now transfer files up to
20 times faster than before which is a
huge deal for large backups and prores
videos which you can now record at 4K
60fps to an external SSD from the iPhone
making it easy to transfer to a Mac for
editing all iPhone 15 models now support
DisplayPort for up to 4K HDR video
mirroring and video output to displays
and TVs in a huge deal to me is being
able to charge other devices like your
Apple watch or airpods directly from
your iPhone 15's USB C Port which can be
a life changer if you're out backpacking
or camping with no power adapters on
hand but there you guys go those are the
top 10 best new features for the iPhone
15 Pro and if you think I missed any
comment them down below and subscribe
for ultimate comparison video coming up
this Friday thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you